Hello
Hi
I miss you
How are you?
actually, my mom was saying you should come over next time and
For a visit that I think it'd be really fun.
Yes
they just want to meet you this time. Mm-hmm
You okay?
Yeah, I'm just tired
okay
um
Remember I said we were going to get the ferry over
But we went over all the days. yeah.
I think I'm gonna have a nap actually
why don't we do this afterwards?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay. Are you not feeling well? No, I'm just tired.
Okay, yeah, all right. Yeah.
Yeah, sure if you have a sleep and
Mommy, where did I put my card for daddy?
Don't be silly. I told you before you've already put it on top of the TV.
They're going round
another "A"
What do you think ?
already good but we could put dots all around.
He  must have got the wrong train into Charing Cross
And this one at 45 past
I guess
if you left your aunt's house at
three you would have been here by may be half...
Why does Johanna have such weird earrings?
Does she?
What's weird about them?
Why does Daddy want to live so far from us?
Oh.. We've talked about this one, please don't start again
Here give me your plate,
You must be starving.
No! Don't!
I don't want to start anything before he comes.
Ryan! No! Ryan! Ryan! Ryan!
come back here please don't speak to me like that
Ryan!
Ryan?
And shortly after that
dad and Joanna,  moved to America, so
I'm sorry you went through that
But I can totally see why you're not so keen about people leaving.
I'm sorry I didn't make you like a welcome home sign.
I think I could probably do without one maybe
So..
do you want to see my photographs from my holiday?
Oh..?
How about this idea,  right?
How about you go and run yourself a nice warm bath
and in the meantime I'll
cook us some red delicious foods and welcome home dinner
and then after it, we can uh
look at the photos together on the sofa.
That sounds perfect.
Can we have cheesecake?
Okay
Thank you for watching, liking, and subscribing
If you want more, why not visit us in person and attend a class?
Or take a look at our shop at the link on your screen now